all right and we are finally live the
last word with Lord kognito any bonta's
no campfire straight Halloween sheriff
addition as we file in who is this oh oh
sorry the last word question there's
absolutely for keeping it very festive I
saw you and the missus yesterday looking
very sparkling on Halloween suits were
fantastic how was it don't
trick-or-treating but how was the party
on party one party was fun had my wife's
brother and his wife in town so hung out
with them it's usually our good friends
kind of get together they do their big
Halloween party every year so we did
this we won couples costume so it was
you know not not the craziest
competition but you know couples we
match because my wife was bo-peep so
yeah she was flyy oh yeah
so headset doesn't quite fit over the
hat but we are Sheriff Woody on this
side of the campfire today but yeah the
world of destiny I think blew away the
campfire because too much stuff came
into town so yeah the tumbleweeds the
fire it's all gone it's all good we
start from the dungeon start from the
bottom so what you been up to this week
obviously can tell what I've been doing
clearly busy man it's a lot of work I've
got a chance to plays much destiny as I
would like got to play some touched a
couple of moods you know some momentum
control and and some the other thing
obviously the the festival you know
saying so it gets run around the candy
and stuff like that but I will be
deferring to you on a lot of heresy I
need to know I see what you did there
sir well place just trying to get back
hopefully this weekend I will get a
chance to play more and salute to a lot
of my PC brothers we've reformed back I
got a dick back on PCs got his issues
resolved we got a couple of I want to
shoot outside to amount my arm my rack
pack
rose from my job they jumped in on
eating the fake and my boy Craig and I'm
saying listen to the show so soluti
y'all it was good give me a chance to
run with you guys on steam yes and yeah
you'll be seeing me more on steam a
little bit more now because I know in
the beginning it was a lot of me on xbox
don't cross a but I got my raid crew I'm
hi listen me I'm a good friend I go my
friends are so anyway I got my a plus
Guardians ready to rock so check for me
I already know on the Lords of gaming on
discord server and stuff like that and I
shout to everybody who was out playing
with us this week you know for as much
as they could
it was fun nice so how's house festive
old you try momentum control like
general idea just like what was it like
when you logged in you're like too much
where do I start when do you finally get
to it yeah I've got to a late shout the
carboxyl in the 11th hour forearm
playing with me oh yeah but we did oh my
I started with the the haunted I like a
haunted forest man it's just fun it's
fun you got your nightmare running
around scaring you chasing you up and
candies dropping and all this good stuff
um
yeah man it's really it's really cool
you know at the end there's still load
they say load trick but you know they
they take away your reward you gotta be
careful when you jump so I definitely
haunted forest I am afraid I don't know
how I feel about the Bray tech yeah
because I obviously I haven't got it but
I like how they set it up in the sense
that you can go it's not like you just
have to go for the big curated role you
can actually go for a regular one with
random roles for Less candy I believe so
um after you have you have to get the
big one first
oh okay cuz it looked like when I saw
the the bounties from evil it looked
like the the random woman was like two
or something and then the big one was
like a thousand but you you would know
yeah I know I was like I mean I thought
and typically like my weapons link I've
been trying to was clear stuff out so it
could have just been full but I was like
I know one requires the master disguise
I didn't look at the other one somebody
in Chad let me know I didn't think it's
gonna check the other ones but you just
pull a random for like what like 150
yeah it look like 150 or 250 away
was it said random role version of the
break tech werewolf and then I shout out
to the console warriors it here put some
respect on that piece to make
PlayStation and Xbox no doubt but oh
that was good that's good Stadium Oh
salute so um yes I think yeah okay cool
so anyway so that was that and then get
momentum control momentum control very
interesting so alright first off
everything is buffed
I mean you you're getting to tapped by
everything you're gonna would like one
trigger with a pulse right we're just
going in a momentum control alright yeah
let's just go straight into it there
that's been I've been playing a decent
amount of that actually just cuz I've
been working on Randy's throwing knife
so okay I mean if you want undying
you've got to get that amongst other
things so you know what it's a good way
to get it with that mode right I have a
video about that that's my battle kills
it's like literally whether you win or
lose the scout rifle kills go quick 150
scout like cut and run one cut and run
Jade rabbit obviously which everybody
seen Jade rabbit cut and run does it to
pretty much anything that's 150 [ __ ] hit
for about anywhere from 200 to 2 to 12
and killing everybody anybody so to
temple once a single shot to the head
whoa oh I'm getting my Randy's always
going down oh I will retweet that video
bro I got I didn't even know you put
that up damn I've been out there talks
about my minimum control and says if you
need kills for this do this that's live
oh no I'm going in because I was I
wasn't gonna get it cuz I was like I
just didn't want to play with a scout I
was just like I don't wanna play the
scout that long but doing this you
probably should oh it's oh it is so on
thank you for saying that yeah I'm
definitely gonna do that that or
mountaintop
fighting lion it's also one yes yes yes
this is the league this is a good low
for that you're right
so yeah I'll do that and then um but
y'all just messing around I seen the
ability stuff that was kind of cool it
literally felt like Call of Duty it was
like
it's fast and it's like well I mean one
hit is everybody start sniping lanes a
lot now though yes everybody fine what
is the matter now think of a map it's
like in the arcology on Titan yes you
got the outside area and yeah here yeah
the outside like you can be on the
stairs and crouch and like you can see
all the way to the other side and people
are literally picking people off from
that little tiny corner to corner so
crazy side lands they're going for ya
time to kill is crazy right now so that
right there you don't get the ability as
much um it's just different you don't
say they just I don't I don't I don't
know how to quantify just yet I mean
it's it's a motor I don't know how
people feel about it I mean I'm not like
oh my god I was like I've been hearing a
lot of like oh my god Scout rifles are
fighting lion and then a whole bunch of
further since you have no radar anyway
right spectra blades listen it is
something I'm checking for I guess if
there's a demand for and people want it
fine you know sample for me I'm like I
don't know it's like for me it's just
been fun to like it does put the
emphasis back on your basic guns it
doesn't worry about like fusions aren't
gonna do it
we recluse is not hardly an option yeah
you won't get close enough like I have
my half Landy it's got decent range up
that's just one that I got a pretty good
rollin I've been using in PV is like a
let me try it 120 126 is to the head
just a to tattle on the head with an
auto Saros I hear with the slow mode is
pretty solid I gotta live in this mode I
just realized I gotta I have the Searles
catalyst and I was dreading doing it oh
yeah you gave now the love this mode a
because all my catalysts I'm getting a
shot the Forte's got cities that eating
this Jade rabbit catalyst in there yeah
but I don't have the might of catalyst
but that would be another one you could
do in here that might be a to tap I
think though but yeah like oh that's
happen it does put the focus on guns now
granted you peek and you're one banged
with us with like out like it's fast
like don't get me wrong you can't be
like peeking on
like if somebody's got sites snipers
will body you Oh easy
yeah cuz Scouts I will so head so I will
say this though
it definitely changes my play style cuz
what I was noticing guys are doing is
when they cap they get a to cap duals
are just hanging out now they will camp
planes all day they gon camp blades they
like yo we got the points you can't even
see us on radar so we're gonna set up
shop and whoever pull up on a or beer
that we control you're getting popped
and you don't even know sometimes where
it's coming from so it will say it's a
different strategy with controlling
zones and and its own control it's
really really fast so you may be on to
something
yeah you got me just off at a catalyst
work I'm gonna be in man now oh it's on
it's on I was like it it's I've seen
very large disparity and matches though
for exactly oh you said like two people
like lock it down especially if like
you're coming from you know a and C and
B's just in this crap point in the
middle and you're trying to get to them
and they just got lanes shut down what
are you like it's what you do it is it
is rough like if you get stuck on one of
those sides and that's why I was like
I'm glad I don't care that much I'm not
one that's gonna take it seriously
because there are points where you walk
out and you're like ah but then there's
also points I get just some like like
five bullets and five scout rifle kills
is just like pop pop pop pop pop I'm
like keep coming keep coming
it's like feed me feed me kills like so
I mean if you don't take this mode
seriously mm-hmm
you can have some fun test out different
weapons like oh let me see what the
pulse rifle does every if it's a one
trigger pull it was like 79 79 80 I'm
like hitting for 240 with a pulse I'm
just like everything hits like a truck
it's it's it's fun everything feels
different not everybody's gonna like it
and I know that but for me I think I'm
actually having a lot of fun just cuz
like it's all good it's all just using
them I mean it does turn into a lot of
scouts but I still have fun good so so
let me ask you this dude
do we know if Moe mental control is now
going to be a permanent mainstay as far
as the rotation or is this like a
seasonal thing that
is coming in conjunction with festival
so right now they said it's only with
festival okay for three weeks they're
gonna see what the feedback is like but
it's in a 66 rotator like for me mayhem
you know clash whatever they throw in
there scorch whatever throw it in there
in the mix like it's just a different
mode and as you said like certain things
for catalyst this is a great way to work
on catalysts because it's all about the
guns you're not worried about supers or
heavies or whatever yeah and you can
even pick up heavy I'm still gonna one
tap you with a scout it's like heavy
doesn't matter yeah I can get some kills
with heavy but you can do so much work
it's crazy
yeah he's spittin bars I I lit the
hollow points commits the pop-pop could
you know I don't snap he's loving convey
he's loving romantic good show you got
bars would it say like the maps you're
like oh how do I play this one cuz some
you're like all right where the
sightlines the new one what does it
fragment is that what it's called yes
yes all it's all like circular and weird
and I don't know the map that well and
I'm just ro you know what they doing
they you know where the circles are a
lot of points there's a lot of those
control points they have a part where
you can jump up through like a gap dudes
are chilling on a gap perched waiting
for you to touch it if you want I'll get
frustrated if I see but it's just it
makes you change your play style so I'm
coming around you get me excited I'll
come and give me some more some more
burn especially for the catalyst it's
going down strictly for catalyst I can
get progression on guns that have been
sitting unfinished catalyst and I
thought of them sitting I mean if you
needed like revoke or kills you could
kill somebody on the toe so I mean
there's their stuff you could do in here
and you still get to go into obviously
competitive for the glory part and it's
gonna feel a little weird but it is one
of those like hey do I want to work on
my scout or I feel like you're saving
you go you miss your dad so
absolutely I'm so yeah not for everybody
but for me I've actually been like
finding myself going in there cuz wanna
know I need Randy's throwing knife so
that's been part of it part of it but
you and I go and I'm like let's just
have some fun I'm not taking it too
seriously
bad enough man so does we get so you
have momentum control that lunch
festival that's what you've jumped into
so the tower is all sorts of decorated
if you guys haven't jumped in yet jump
in the AVA LaVon take decorations have
thrown up on the tower so it is
everywhere the tree just sprouted up in
the middle if you guys can hear one of
the Wolves outside she's partly the
Wolves I had yeah it's the first time I
already had it and if I can hear her
just enough like she's probably cuckoo
through D suffer yeah the door so it's
through door and through my headset and
I know if it's that clear so so yeah a
festival we've got the haunted forces
back you've got candy everywhere make
sure you pick up your mask and when you
wear your mask like I wear my mask and I
went to the new public thing which will
get you later on the moon like a
thousand candy like so fast it's so easy
to get like so you swear it like they're
not challenging you you'll have plenty
of candy don't worry about the candy and
don't like go chases and candy down in
the haunted forest
you'll get that stuff later yeah even in
crucible I was wearing a mask for a
couple of bounties like for for kill I
was just racking up maybe it was easy
yeah so what do you think of 100 forest
any changes do you notice anything
majors I feel about the same what what
mod are you going with I went with the
one that gives you regeneration on
precision hits position kills and the
final perk of it's the one in the middle
because there's one that gives you
something damn it I think mom one gives
you more damage against the nightmares
or whatever into terrorist as well as
the precision kill regeneration and the
other one is one that gives you
something like resistance in the air and
then I forgot what the third one does
but I went with that second one which
one did you go with I went for the one
I'm trying to actually check right now
the last one for the damage against the
terror is just the bosses will die
faster yes that was the one I went for I
mean the heavy not like whatever it is
take one of them cuz that heavy ammo
just like falls to have exactly
shout to level year vampiric
oh wait I want with vampiric I'm just
checking Twitter just to see like to
make sure the deletes are up my wife
just was like he bounces his trust as
woody and he just said there's a snake
in my boots you should definitely be
watching this wife calling me out thanks
[ __ ] I hope the lady e in the building
the lady of summer salute she first
serve up that's funny yeah that's pretty
good so yeah but no haunted forest has
been what you get to for branch I got to
ate with randoms yesterday
not quite 9 which is what you need but I
got to eight I only get a few runs I got
up to like six or seven way I like to
have a bad stuff but I got to get back
in it I can't run though it's it's fun I
like the boat it it's something about
when that big nightmare comes to chase
you through thing it really adds a
little boy night but you can yeah yeah
and what I like you can't see him you
just hear him so it's that don't like it
it fits I like that the lighting is very
obstructive so that you know normally
play infinite force you could see so far
ahead right
but with this it the Lighting's load you
got a really search around I like it man
I mean it's it's a cool festive mode I
think they found their pocket for the
festival laws and think about this
remember how how how far Festool of the
Lost has come I mean I remember we used
to call the festival of the cost didn't
have really any mode to it I really like
how how it evolved I feel like it is and
he's evolved really well and I'm cool
with it you know saying I mean we Percy
I don't I I actually look I think this
is like now moving up to like maybe
number two and number three the dawning
is still my number one I love the
dawning no balls and stuff yeah there's
no balls and then wanted to me got the
best gear don't get me wrong
first of all this is this is this is
this is like this is a high level gear
as far as the skeleton suits the knee or
not house okay
festivals government so this is probably
one of their best its festivals ever if
I had to rank it it's like
number two or three as far as events but
yeah definitely for me dawning and
what's the one that we got the suits
just recently they're carried over into
armor 2.0 what's the name of that one
Wow everybody on the podcast is like hey
I know exactly what this is because I
can totally tell you yes yeah you have
mine farts at some points let us know
what's the ones that we just got they
have it that we just got we always
revisit our memories and and we pray at
the Statue and we get the the good gear
and I'm so we was in the aerial zone we
was in a European Aryan aerial zone
salsa's yeah thank you thank you spidey
sense his spidey sense went off solstice
there we go there we go so soldiers
yes solstice dawning is my number one
solstice is up there but festivals
coming them I like festival I go front
yeah it's in a good place it definitely
got some crap the first time through
festival of it cost but they learn their
lesson and I think they bounced the
world there's some cool stuff everything
will be available for bite bright dust
at some point which is keen so like if
you've been saving up your bright
doesn't you're like hey I really want
this thing cool get it now if you're a
fairly new player do you think that
you're gonna be able to get all of it
probably not but if there's one cool
thing that you want to earn you probably
can you just probably can't earn all of
it unless you've been hoarding it like I
have so 44 days down to 37,000
brightness I'd probably be right there
with you if I bought all the stuff I
want to so mmm-hmm I feel you there but
yeah what's like for the cosmetics I
know the skeleton suits definitely have
like your name on those what does it go
I mean are you going for the broom are
you getting like bat ship Batmobile
you have to bat the bat one is me I was
feeling at yeah a lot yeah but
everything looks cool but I can't front
like it's just they do bungees artists
do such a good job of just playing
around in the spirit of Halloween
industry like they really
really nailed it so all our stuff look
cool I think for me definitely will be
the bat ship and skeleton suits offer it
those those are going down what about
you what are you what are the must-have
items for you I mean for me mmm
the broom I think it's a must mm-hmm
just cuz it's a cool place
it's like ship ships you see an orbit
and they're like hey I got a ship you
actually ride around on your broom you
get to see a little more often so yeah
yeah that one for sure it seems really
cool mm-hmm I don't know some of those
are like ultra cool when I sit there and
look at all of them the skeleton heads
pretty cool mm-hmm the tombstone emote
definitely might have to happen just for
ya I don't tend to troll in PvP much but
you know if somebody teabags me and I
get him later it would be a fitting
thing just to put that on there on their
hosts I will say this though only
nitpick I was hoping for a couple more
months like I remember one festival came
out we have Michael Jackson dances like
I was hoping for just a couple more and
most don't get me wrong I'm gonna say
some of that stuff I guarantee is all
the like dancing copyright stuff that
other companies went through they're not
touching that they're they're saying
they got the little like foot shimmy and
stuff going on but like copyrighted or
like well-known dances now they're they
don't need any heat they're gonna play
nice with all that stuff I think so yeah
it looks like yeah they go on the other
route now with ships and sparrows and
stuff like that he boats us a little
minimal this year yeah it's still fun
though like I mean still some cool stuff
mm-hmm
and then the auto-rifle did you get the
auto-rifle yet not yet not yet do you
have the werewolf sir not yet I'm
probably like 10 strange coins away
because you have to buy all the masks so
you need like 150 strange coins
chocolate strange going so not bad to
get honestly if you just play through
like every crucible matches for you go
do stuff like you know altars are
nightmares those are one it goes pretty
quick like just spend a mostly on that
you'll be pretty good absolutely normal
game play from what I saw shout out to
cool guy he had a great review over
stuff like that and just saying it's I
mean it's a good workhorse
it's probably not gonna top the meta
it's a certain it's the 450 Auto so
mm-hmm
they're not like in the best spot but I
mean we go have fun he still had some
success with it it's got some decent
perks on it PvE it's actually like if
autos are in a decent spot if you need
one that's gonna have to use like
overload rounds for example you got to
put it on something it's gonna be a
pretty good pretty good one because it's
also getting really good perks on it
it's got a range master work it's set up
pretty well that curated one is solid I
don't know what all the roles can be
like if there's a perfect god role or
anything but the curated alone is
definitely worth like putting in your
inventory if nothing else because it is
a solid auto rifle for sure it's it's
absolutely solid
if the meta ever shifts it's usable now
no give it wrong it's it's completely
usable now like you said a good point
with the with the artifact using either
the barrier rounds that's a good point
because um in the kinetic slot if you
want to not you know you're putting your
recluse away for a second you know don't
be let's be real we know the eventual
nerf is gonna come so the meta will
shift you know this is something I say
hold on to use your anti barrier use
whatever use you're gonna put on that
bad boy it'll be a kinetic spot and it's
a good addition so I agree I think out
the cooler we get cool guy back I like
cool guy you got some great video
they'll hand cannon one was gonna range
ones crazy yes absolute the cool guy
bring them back but I can't fire so yeah
like it's been it's cool like it's not
an overly crazy over-the-top mode it's
about what I expected we got a weapon
this time with random roles which is
nice we got the forest you can go
through candies pretty easy to earn
you've got your matchmaking if you need
it you've got your firewall if you don't
want it I don't yes I don't see a whole
lot of incentive to go try and solo this
thing you know there's like is it really
it's just bragging rights probably more
than anything be like how far can you
get by yourself it's like well if I beat
everything else that lunch this week I
guess I'll go do that but there's so
much stuff going on this week it is
crazy but it is I mean it gives you the
option so it's right what what I would
say is if they're gonna do that they
need incentive kind of like what they
did with we will talk about with a
Harrison so um yeah man like I don't I
don't know what that is maybe again you
have to put some type of reward to
incentivize your even if it's just an
emblem even if it's just that so you
know I don't know which which Guardians
don't want to match me but you have the
option not to that is that is your call
mmm yeah that Final Four festival I'd
say that pretty well covers most of it
yeah it's meant standard Halloween stuff
have fun with it enjoy get Cosmetics if
you want them but again remember and
they're optional so don't freak out you
know I was surprised a real quick um
Horror Story no like they didn't bring
it back yeah I guess don't cuz one one I
missed out I had it on my xbox account
but that's that did god I brought over
something like damn I could never get
Horror Story again yeah you know so that
kind of sucked but I'll just like I
guess you know I can live with it but I
was just curious I was like I guess
they're looking at it like you know what
you know kind of what look something you
should have been there when you know
yeah that's one of those you're not
always gonna be able to get mmm it's a
450 Auto anyway yeah and it has rampage
Zen moment flared magwell and red dot so
mm-hmm
its overall bonus uh yep not crazy perks
that I honestly think the new ones
probably going to be better so it's
still a 450 not gonna be overall that
different I don't think so mm-hmm
you shout out to bender with seven
months of subs thank you for the support
there sir yes it was like if you didn't
have a war story yeah you're a
completionist might have a little itch
on his side but overall get the new one
I think she'll be just fine the new
curate it's better anyway perks wise for
sure
does it have rampages podium I know it's
got a range master work yeah it's got
it's all good I was trying to pull up
the vendors but dim isn't working with
me right now
it's being slow dramatic likes the
werewolf a bit better yeah I mean autos
are like 450 autos is even cool guy was
saying it's like they're not in like an
amazing space they're not just like oh
they're really cool in PvP now they're
really not like they're just there
but generally they're usable so this is
I think a better version you should you
should have been there and Sheriff what
he was on the last word yes there you go
oh my goodness so yes ah oh yeah that
pretty much covers festivals so you got
three weeks of that goes through the
19th at reset which reset time will be
changing for bungie
yes so just a little reminder for that
one normally resets are 10:00 a.m.
Pacific during the American daylight
savings time so if you're around the
world do you be me but like what are you
guys talking about
but coming this weekend Sunday that will
be changing so daily reset will after
Saturday it will be Sunday and onward
will be 9:00 a.m. Pacific so one hour
back
that means er launches an hour earlier
so that means we definitely got to
finish our podcast so those types of
things but yeah so just an hour change
for daily resets so make sure and check
your time buns you put a little thing
out in the table this week but that's
just a a live thing for us in America I
think UK actually did their daylight
savings time last week which kind of
threw things off so now now they're
gonna change so everything come back
yeah it's not Sunday it's just the fact
that every daily reset willard's zero on
Friday weekly reset on Tuesday it's
always 9:00 a.m. Pacific time for bungie
now so might have to adjust yourself
accordingly we'll see so what else was
there when you logged into your
character on that first day what what
you see yo first of all shout out to
Bungie the setup was really cool we got
Aris we got I don't know what she doing
I don't know why she messed with the
space DeVito again and when she don't
learn and I'm worried now I'm worried as
she didn't she done got corrupt it's I'm
gonna happen I mean she smirked I don't
know what to make it is yeah she have a
motion she doesn't smile someone like
her like the corners of her lips like
even with level much less like no like
no no you know metal yeah why is she
touches her so much this
I have one of two theories one you know
obviously during the campaign she's been
you know come composing master plan on
how to combat for us to get inside ship
and and to use you know the the the
darkness stuff kind of against them to
see what's going on
you know um clearly maybe she has some
plan and she's like yeah I got you
or she's fumbling around and they got
her cuz she's a little too curious so I
I'm telling the lean toward the latter
that's just my guess yeah the - go for
it
no like I mean she has some big plans I
don't know if she paired up with Marcus
off doing some stuff with her where
there's like a big thing maybe Mara sobs
bad and she got turned by the space
Doritos like I don't know how deep it
goes I really don't
so what means got telling you he is
heiress to be trusted after touching
space Doritos the smirk on her face is
not fitting her character so I'm
probably gonna say no exactly that's
what I'm going Brett's that's me just
because like she touched it first and
she's like what the hell's going on and
she's just like and that may be on her
side that she's like she's been through
literally Helen back her fireteams
totally gone and she's like either this
could be bad or good but maybe this is
the only way she may see that we have a
chance to beat the darkness or face the
veil or whatever the hell they're called
so maybe it's her way of leg maybe at
least if I can get in like a spy type
thing but again you don't know if
they're gonna control her so it's an
interesting twist because I will say
like I've been getting very close to you
know eros as far as like the story with
the campaign and the fire you know her
fire a-team and stuff like that so she's
really become I can't believe I she's
really become a sympathetic figure
for me like I I like doing those
memories and listen to her talk about
stuff and you know I really it adds more
context cuz prior to that I really she
was just crazy to me I just you know I
it was I didn't have any feeling for I
was just like okay what do you want us
to do you know I don't know if I should
trust you yet like I actually was
trusting her and like feeling for her
like damn you know maybe she went to a
lot and she still suffer him but now I'm
like
let's do this danger going to girls
dangerous a they gave us a little uh
like dream sequence in black Gardens I'm
think if they can get on her head like
that I don't know what they're gonna do
she's been she's part high of at this
point I don't we don't know what she is
but maybe she's just gonna be like the
one that can like she's the gonna be the
she's the ring that controls them all
she's the lord of the ring it's like
okay I don't know if she can control it
though cuz like that looked like bad
news when she smiled so yeah after that
you know obviously that opened up a
chain of events that has happened on the
moon and obviously we have our dungeon
we have some new events going on in the
moon so either had to be something up
there I was well that's a I do you I'm
gonna defer this whole sex segment to
you but I just want to say because I
didn't I didn't play I purposely didn't
play it because I knew I was gonna have
enough time to really dedicate so all I
will say is from what I've seen as far
as the new events you know that's a
great new addition of an activity on the
moon that I know you might be very happy
about you know aesthetically as far as
the pit you know I'm gonna just say wow
it looked really cool I did watch a
little bit of spoilers I didn't got a
lot cuz I helped I normally I would just
stay away but I just couldn't cuz I
think it's the Scarlett aesthetic
they're like that most Reds and just
descending and it looked really cool
from friends I that I spoke to they are
saying better than chat it throw so I
need to speak to e I'm set this up this
is your segment I'm gonna sit here
attentively what do you think about both
of these events and let's start with the
moon and then the other dungeon so
altars of sorrow you have to actually
start with before you can do the dungeon
so you're gonna see one before the other
so you don't have a choice
altars of sorrow is kind of cool it's a
unique take on kind of the escalation
twisted with blind well a little bit
you'll basically have like a glowing
section that's doing its thing and then
you have to kind of eel that's the one
you actually have to end up defending
because another one will spawn
and the enemies will start coming from
that to the one you're trying to defend
the little guys don't really matter
though right they're all nice it's
nothing major
it's the bosses and it's all on this
timer the more enemies you kill you get
like seconds add it on to your timer
you're always starting at kind of a base
and trying to add to it as the enemies
come over like up over a hill or come
through they tend to have light pretty
obvious choke points which is kind of
nice because you can just set up like
well of radiance and just like mow them
down or just line them up and you can
work pretty well as you go through like
the first four tiers they're all gonna
work similar you have more nightmares
there sometimes we're like hey kill
certain um number nightmares you'll take
a pause then they've got like sword
Knights that come out you got to kill
the sword knights to be able to break
the shield was the shield's on the
Wizards killed a certain number of
wizards get back to killing the
nightmares
if the nightmare which by the way I
think this is possibly where some of
those mods from the nightmare hunts are
gonna be a little more beneficial a big
one if the nightmares get to your little
like home beacon that you're trying to
defend for that round it's minus ten
seconds whoa so it can go quickly which
kind of bleeds you in and there's four
there's like tier 1 tier 2 tier 4 cheer
for there might be tier 5 I don't
remember but I think it's after five I'm
pretty sure is the final wave and the
final wave is well I only did it on
basically the first day so I've seen
phogoth the biggest thing people seem to
want like you can take all the time you
need to kill the boss but people don't
seem to understand that the hardest
thing to kill is the nightmares because
they are trying to run from their little
spotty points up to this little circle
you're trying to defend mm-hmm so yeah
there's a tier 5 when you hold on let me
clear my throat to discuss ready then
I'm a challenge and with a dramatic
question that comes later I see a
dramatic mm well yeah we don't get to
that
the thing about the last wave where you
fight whatever boss it is apparently
it's a rotating boss like there's three
so three bosses three possible weapons
those kind of I think coincide the boss
will take time to kill period that's
fine
the nightmares there's like a couple
that spawn on each side four of them
come up together their heart is held to
kill - forty seconds you're done wow it
is really really really I haven't
finished the final wave yet Wow i watch
that though what's the strats looking
like so the strats are like one is like
literally stand in their way and
obstruct their view right like try and
be that person is in August knifes like
grenade launchers the biggest things
don't waste all your heavy important
ammo super all that stuff on the boss
the boss you can whittle down I don't
think he's gonna go march into it if he
does let's it's the nightmare so
focusing on the nightmares as soon as
like hey do some damage Whittle them
down take your time manage ads and also
if you don't kill the boss so quickly
you'll probably have time to kill more
ads add more time to your thing so if
one does make it you won't instantly
lose gotcha so it's all about killing
the little guys to make sure you have
time going focusing on the nightmares
and then whittling down Big Boy it's not
I mean the video I saw where somebody
finished that there were nine people
yeah nine people can manage it a little
better cuz just like exploration
protocol okay same thing you need the
big group so it isn't gonna take a
pretty beefy group like I kind of
orchestrate it it's not just gonna be
like everybody dumped your damage on the
boss don't do it I'm I have debated on
making a video but I'm just like how not
to do it just don't like the first four
waves are not that bad over five however
many there are they're not that bad like
them there's one nightmare that spawns
at a time it's got an icon on the map
but as soon as you see like - and then
like four icons coming and there's like
four guys walk marching in the middle
nobody can stop that many and it's just
like - ten - there - like that one's
pretty cool you got a hive themed weapon
apparently since I haven't beat it I
don't know that can come from it whether
it's the there's the new pulse that's
out there for the dream
weapons you've got the new sniper rocket
launcher and shotgun I did get the
shotgun from the dungeon that's the slug
one though so I'm not sure they love
with it but some people like it look
embedded in garden to salvation weapons
aesthetically that's an opinion thing
you like the garden salvation ones
they're not bad late I got that yeah
okay I mean they fit that theme
they're very vex if I have like this
wide but I mean they're like they're vex
weapons they especially like the hand
get like some people are just like I
wanna use the hand cane because it looks
cool like they are very unique looking
weapons they're pretty dissolute Lee you
just like say you guys like the hive
theme that's the difference but yeah the
hive prickly boys are definitely yeah
you know what I knew it made me want to
play with thorn when I sorted the thorn
ornament of it scarlet thorn ornament
[Laughter]
but yeah that is kind of the big thing
it feels like for that final boss phase
is the boss can be slow the nightmares
are your focus like Papa super on those
like manage the ads build up your super
that way like share supers tether user
heavies izanagi's this like damn
powerful still so all that type of stuff
is gonna work
mmhmm yeah biggest thing it's like a
beat the final tier a couple times got
the shotgun twice that's all I said I
think it's a different rotation got the
pulse from the dungeon rolled with
outlawed kill clip while I'm jealous we
got some new weapons rolling in which is
nice some people say is it what is it
enough is it good better otherwise but
overall like you see the whole section
and then you're like what are these like
random little nightmares going on what
does it matter
and then finally ultra I'm sorrow comes
like oh of course
there we go I'm in shadow town does
she's like yeah there's this thing in
the video that we think is coming at
some point and sure enough here it is so
you walk in and you do that and you need
to kill a certain number of nightmares I
think it's like 20 or something like
that and then get to like tear wave 3
and open the chest at the minimum so
mm-hmm once you do that then you go back
to eros and then she's like hey there's
this thing
we gotta go down deep so this is the new
dungeon hidden heresy mm-hmm
a grand of people have already so loaded
this thing and flawless did so they're
far beyond me which is fine but you open
you walk in and you're like okay so what
are we doing
I was with Prescott I think deputy
Prescott I know he's not making us go
yeah so just playing with him for a
little bit
just cuz we were goofing around on
altars and stuff it was like Haiti was
like I'm debating on doing it by myself
but it was like first time probably
won't or anything so come on let's go
yeah if you walk in and you're like just
to try and get in this thing you start
you know you go in the Scarlet keep you
can stand on the little section where
everybody figured it wasn't you start
falling down it's not that big of a deal
you get to the bottom and you're still
kind of going down a long ways you know
how far down does this go and then
finally it opens up ish it opens up like
you're kind of looking off the edge of
like the Grand Canyon
because then when you get to the edge
and you look down oh my god it goes a
long ways down but it is such an amazing
sight when you get there like I sent a
tweet out - yeah so it's like I think
Andrew I'm gonna get his name wrong -
because it tweeted a 900 address yeah
because I know he was involved with
shattered throne and then tweeted out it
was like the opening shot when you look
down to see the scale of it's called the
necropolis and it's the first section in
the dungeon you look down just see the
scale it was like dammit they nailed it
again yes like for me it was so cool so
fire it has the feeling of how far am I
gonna go down there see this is a pit
into like the center of the earth type
thing you're going way down fire so
pretty cool
just opening visuals like also I mean
similar it's like you looked up in the
shattered throne going to the top we're
looking right you can't see the bottom
of this thing and that's the idea is
like you you're looking down you cannot
see the bottom so how far do you want me
to go on mechanics of what I've seen and
know like to have a just kind of I know
a decent amount of it I've kind of
looked ahead for the final bit because
I've had an idea I was on the third
encounter and we knew what to do we just
couldn't put together the survival sakes
so we knew it
so from what I've seen you know then
there's like these uh symbols that you
kind of gotta look out for almost
reminiscent of last wish I feel
yeah there's kind of symbols here and
stuff yeah so you're kind of looking for
certain things to match to go to certain
areas there's stuff like that and um you
know what did you feel about that part
and then obviously I want to get past
that to the platforming and then finally
to the encounters with certain swords
and stuff like that did you have to do
certain things and stuff like that with
yeah so the opening section that
Acropolis is basically built on this
entire cliff wall so you're gonna be
kind of going up and down there's some
elevators to go around and you've got
symbols that you've seen some of them
out when you open those little treasure
chests where you have to shoot the three
symbols there's a few of those there's a
few new symbols we haven't seen and the
idea is you're looking for the rooms
were you actually gonna find the bosses
and there's gonna be these three little
chains in the back that tell you which
rooms you actually need to go to mmm so
those are gonna be the ones that
actually have the bosses you need to
kill no dice randomised I'm guessing
random I've only done in Amasya
okay cool but I would assume it's set up
to be able to be random so yeah I would
assume I mean the same shadow throne was
random so when I saw what was going on
two different symbols and kind of
figured it's got a similar feel to the
opening of shadow throne like hey once
you kill this section or you know what
to do then you know you can go over here
gotcha
mm-hmm yeah said friends like there's
apparently an emblem tied to the soul of
flawless oh you know I'm gonna get it
I'm gonna I'm gonna brick it's the third
encounter that actually Prescott and I
got to and it is probably the hardest
one mm because it's a it's a defense
thing like you it's a survival thing so
there's a couple tweaks I saw and
triumph score by the way 300 tramps
floor for so flawless look with Jana gay
people yeah we'll talk about what
complaining did later too but that's but
this is legit complaints like you do
something like that you should get real
action thanks so absolutely absolutely
but yeah so when you go in one will be a
night one will be a wizard and one will
be a sugar yes now as you're wandering
throughout all this
like tripping over the wrong room you're
gonna fall into there's some great
wandering ogres just shoot those from
are far away don't even mess with them
and then you'll have like a night
outside of each door you got to kill
that to the door can opening to see if
it's the right room or not mm-hmm and
then there's these like big boy sword
knights and shout out to the guy on
twitter i've retweeted a couple of his
he's one of the Bungie guys and he's one
of the artists like making all these
amazing freakin characters go look him
up I got to figure out what his name is
again because I know I have retweeted
the living crap out of his stuff because
it looks just absolutely stellar his
name is Roderick wise I'm gonna go quick
his okay Twitter right now in chat
basically he's gonna do a breakdown he's
got the accursed sword bearer which is
the one I'm talking about he's like a
knight with like kind of your spiky
theme but he's gold under green glow
he's got the big boy boss he's got the
Wiz he's got uncle
he's got phogoth so like you want to see
some amazing like renders of some of
these bosses they are amazing so please
check that man out that is such crazy
work so you come across these accursed
sword bearers you drop a sword this
sword works different than the hive
sword previously normally that thing has
like a timer on it it just sits there in
your hand and loses like a mo mm-hmm
this one does not so you can wander
around anywhere you want well so you can
just move around with it okay okay so
the way it works spoilers if you guys
don't want to know the mechanics if you
want to go in blind and figure it out
yourself I'm gonna tell you how to do
the first encounter and that's all this
also applies later on so the idea with
the sword you have three techs you have
the light a sec you have your heavy
attack which actually shoots a
projectile like Black Talon and then you
have your block well your light attack
is your swing that's how you killed a
knight you can only take melee damage
though but if you shoot the projectile
at him he's immune
oh I see what they do okay if it's the
wizard since it's really hard to melee
those guys you have to hit them with the
projectile now the shriek I'll say long
ass time the Shrieker we're like we're
trying we're trying to smash it with
supers because you can charge up a super
it takes a little while all you have to
do is block
took us much longer and shatta I think
it was Seth and my chat was like try
blocking I was like and it's just like
ding-ding-ding-ding-ding dead I'm like
yep that's it so we're like running
around running in a sword animal hey let
me go get another sword let me see if I
can charge it super that stuff but yeah
I was blocking with the sword to send
that stuff back and I was like perfect
so nice nice light heavy and block and
that's how you kill the three when all
three die then eventually you'll see a
big glowing beam of like hey here's the
door going in so that's the opening
section of necropolis pretty similar
before I don't know if the symbols will
be the same because I'm debating on
making a map but instead of like a
horizontal map it's gonna be like the
vertical wall to figure out where
everything is gonna be so mm-hmm
I may do that at some point as well but
then when that's done then you kind of
work down into the next section I'm
gonna probably forget the order of
operate order here I think the ogres are
next if somebody can correct me or not
but I think it is maybe not so okay
there's two things and this could be out
of order but it's not that big of a deal
there's one point where you get done
with the first section and it's either
after the ogres which I'll get to
describing in a second or it's just
before it but there's like a wall of
like hotel doors yes so the first time I
was like hey let me see and it's got so
what happened it's got its got the taken
king phallic wall oh the first time you
jump in the door I do that and get like
poked in bent and Prescott's over there
just like dying yeah I definitely got
smashed in the face the first time oh
definitely got you mm-hmm so that
happens after that and I was like okay
stay up here at the top I'm gonna go
check because you can stand on the ledge
you just can't let go in the doorway
there's a bunch of ledges on my right
let me go check see what's going on and
not even like I didn't even mean to do
it you can actually I'm pretty good site
from it from the top but there's like a
between doorways there's a crack and the
walls like this one looks different let
me see and then it like the whole world
changes like words pop up on the screen
like oh you're in the next area my got
it
got it okay I got it fair enough yeah
buddy
good to see the humor so that's the next
one yeah and that is after that because
I know the next section goes into the
next so then the next one is there's
probably a game and somebody in chat can
probably figure out a way to describe it
so you have little tunnels that you can
run around in in this next section it's
a little bit of a maze well it's kind of
like a stealth game because you have to
you have to run away from big giant
ogre's that are immune you can't damage
you can't touch him so you just got to
run around and yeah so there's like
there's these little baby caves
oh no it's you're never gonna kill them
they're little baby caves Neil hey let
me run in here okay then you can like
maybe the ogre will go away if you're
not in sight you'll hear them run away
then you speak out and be like I do I go
over here so it's trying to figure out
the maze of all of that and they don't
have the intensity of Trevor or is it
more slower paint stealthy like dogs of
more more dogs so this is more dogs it's
stealthy we creep in but just this
menacing thing there's right looking
there's three so this is dogs with ogres
yeah but okay that's why oh yeah they
won't insta kill you like the dog
howling wipe but they will definitely
kill you fast if and if they smash you
you're screwed so you have like a tiny
window to be like a slide through the
doorway and like take half damage and
barely squeak it out but yeah there's
yeah it's gonna be that I'm sure
somebody's gonna find like the perfect
path rotation or something but the idea
in this section is you're trying to find
three different rooms that will have
Knights and the Knights upon death will
drop an orb the orb you have to run to
one of three doorways okay open the next
section so picture it is like a giant
kind of V tilt it off to a side slightly
one of them's up here one of them is
over here one of them is over here and
there's like a 3/4 Norway opening and
you have to open each one of them see
like open one okay let me go hide again
okay now I gotta go run through these
tunnels and try not dying
Oh found the new one now where the hell
is the next door cuz you can't do the
same two or three times you have to hit
all three so you have to find the three
Knights figure out where those rooms are
run to each one hide hold on your little
charge so it's just like running and
hiding and dodging and charging so it's
fun like it's a cool different mechanic
and honestly it's one of those that's
may not be everybody's favorite but I
think it's it's cool it sounds cool it's
so I like to change it how do you think
like if you can you know if you're
patient you should be fine don't force
it don't like haze right out there maybe
you can slide through it's like no wait
for him to go away go out a different
doorway trend pulls attention somewhere
else don't mess with them they will they
will ruin your day so that looks pretty
cool part three so then once you get all
three doors open after that when all
three doors are open and kind of kick
off the next encounter the first time
you can technically turn back around and
wander the whole may so if you want to
go get a feel for it afterwards then you
can but in the moment it's a bit hectic
so I think we got it I got a pretty good
feel for it after spending some time
because I was like hey before we go do
this next thing because I don't even
know what it's gonna be like can we
wander around in here because we can so
I got a decent feel where everything's
that nice nice yep but it'll run at some
point it's got to happen so it's gonna
be the solo light solo like get through
it once to like die multiple times
figure out the encounter of course I can
tell you it's the third encounter that's
gonna ruin me though same as the ogre
ogre was the third encounter because
guess what this is gonna be the same
damn way so on this one Kings fall
totems the very first section you have
one of those to manage now you get a
there are like the three doorways swear
everything spawns and you have one totem
you have to stand in so you're like
basically taking fire from three
directions so it's that's what it's like
the solo parts gonna be the hardest like
I've seen people do it and you think of
bubble Titan what you thinkin bubble
Titans gonna be really solid I think
there are boomers still remember the
totems still had boomers so I got those
to manage say uh saint-14 now most of
its rate the problem is all the acolytes
they went to drag grenade throwing
school and they're just like me
[Laughter]
it's like damn okay so a butt ton of
grenades mm-hmm boomers when you dunk
the orb mm-hmm so I was watching that oh
I didn't see glad to it but I'm sure
multiple people have but you have to do
it six times you have to Duncan orbs six
times at the door while making sure
somebody's like kind of cycle you
through the totem steer that's tough so
that's tough because they are requiring
that stand in the middle on that plate
now how's that time looking those that
timer is it quick is it is it know you
got some foot you're you're kind of
forgiving yeah you can go like wander
off kill the thing come back remember
step on it for a bit yeah you gotta you
can't just completely leave it be so the
idea with that from what I saw I saw dad
I don't know if this is good bad strata
otherwise was just I was like we were
working through I was working on random
stuff and yeah just like let's see what
some of these guys are doing he did its
work the Boomers spawn when you dunk hmm
so pick up three mm-hmm drop them half
of mine next time keep like cycling
they're like life cycle like pick them
up moving back and forth while you're
managing ads then when you think you're
ready dunk dunk dunk pop your bubble use
the bubble to kill the Boomers and then
probably repeat the thing now I don't
know if that's right or not but I was
like in my head I can see that at least
making sense but there are just so many
ads god bless your solo run ah I'm just
thinking about that run that's wrong
that's where that's where we stopped so
I've seen the rest generally so I have
an idea what else is there but that is
the part that I know is going to kill me
the most that is the one for me to
practice even now like I could sit in
there like I can try and learn it now I
was practicing it it's like and like so
I saw dad oh he's like somebody's like
hey he switched to a bow because you get
single-tap an acolyte just the boom and
just kind of pick them off where you
need to any any arm what's the question
any priority in shields that you have to
deal with is it a lot of void guys
there's literally no shields okay so you
just tough dude he's tough does everyone
match yeah some beefy from different
angles yep mmm and just all the grenades
all the time so they just chuck him oh
all the time and then you occasionally
have curse the roles that show up like
after you do like the big dunk face oh
yeah there's more chaos to manage say a
helm of saint-14 with a bubble for that
for those sections may be big again I
got it potentially watch some other
people see what it's all about or figure
out my own but other people have done it
so I probably don't need to reinvent the
wheel but that is gonna be the hard part
now it's like three people like hey one
person stand there hey keep it off
acolytes you go do this now there's a
buff you get I don't think it kills you
I actually haven't seen what the buff
really does I don't know if it just
makes you easier to kill okay or to be
killed I should say that one is curse
curse of suffering or something like
that and that's the one that adds up
over the time when you dunk a ball it
goes back down to like one mm-hmm so
keeping it high makes you really easy to
kill so that's why I like waiting too
long to dunk is not the greatest like if
you like oh go get one orb and then it
takes you like six years ago get the
next one you're gonna be a lot easier to
kill but then the debate is like okay do
i dunk or do I like kill the dunk one
stay a little more survivable kill the
two boomers cuz then if you like dunk
three you have like two and two boomers
to get doubles up top so it gets a bit
chaotic so that one's gonna be crazy
then you get to the next section which
is more the all the rotating spiny
swingy crazy stuff so it looks like the
drop down in there doesn't seem too bad
but it's the more just like it's a
jumping puzzle I mean you're gonna be
moving around not like transl and a lot
of looping self in trouble you know how
I despise it how I'm terrible I Oh am I
in trouble or is it doable
it seems doable like I say that cuz I've
done I did was for the worm on every
character I know it's all doable so and
I can do that I'll know that you guys
gotta speak from a warlock respect I've
played I did it as a warlock and
honestly the no no no okay I'm just
sayin what do you think
my experience will be being that I'm
terrible at jumping later I've gotten
better 82d to all this may be harder for
you let's just say for yours you it'll
be challenging for you so I was like the
main reason is I think everybody's
probably gonna have some learning like
if you like if you watch the pattern be
like okay and fall over here is a safe
spot okay we fall down watch this thing
fall over here here's the safe spot take
some of the following slow but Annie
it's not like you're trying to land on
little baby platforms like a whisper or
angled things it mostly just seems like
if you rush it you don't catch the big
chandelier swinging by that's gonna
smack you like if you go too fast mm-hmm
I think that's one of those things and
where the Warlock is you do kind of
float and I think that's where like the
flu the slower floof while if you time
it right you should have no problem just
like okay cool safe landing fine but if
you're like trying to like jump a spot
if you need to do that at some point I
feel like my Titan does that better my
warlock because I can kind of I can
glide a little faster but yeah I know
there's some flight going on in there
overall I think that section is like you
just have to figure out where you've got
to go there's like three symbols you're
gonna figure out where the Wizards are
at go kill the Wizards I don't think
it's too chaotic and that one's just
like more like a time thing okay and
then we culminate until like in a final
encounter now this one I think I've seen
yeah this is the big boy beefy guys
sadly they spoiled him but yes that is
big lava night man so that guy's name is
since I just had the guy's Twitter up
anyway
so magma instrument of me Foreman
torment yeah so he quite literally yeah
he is on fire and he is a big boy crazy
night and the idea is they kind of bring
them a can't expect it's kind of like a
mini raid well what you had to do with
the sword blow if there's a night you
gotta go hit him with the mail if
there's a wizard you got to send the
projectile if there's a Shrieker you're
gonna block it again you're getting the
orbs picking it up dunking him once you
do that then the center section you have
to be in the center greens
action to do damage to the boss okay
it's like this there's like the outer
area where you can fight and then
there's this like ring with like the
three spots where you can dunk and in
there like the floor glows green big boy
stands in there so you gotta be
relatively close to do damage to them
mmm so after a little while then the big
crystal turns the fire get out of there
and probably cycle through so it's
probably however long it takes you to do
it is like how much damage you can do in
there not get smashed by big fire sword
and if you feel like you gotta like kind
of touch and go then may take you along
a one-hitter quitter when he died so it
down I'm sure if you're staying in under
it
cuz it's a giant flame sword like ten
times the size of your body if it's not
a one hit kill I would be floored
projectile shooting or Z melee attacking
it looks like a melee and this is from a
brief video so I could be wrong melee
smashed the ground big lava blight fire
pool on the ground type so he's in the
middle of this little arena kinda yep
and number three that you fought before
what the sort mechanics are where
they're like off on kind of their own
little paths like he's in the center and
they're off on like three different
Forks like out from now can they all
apply DPS at you I don't want that's the
idea I think like hey clear this one out
bring the orb back don't you gosh okay
go here go here now there's probably ads
there always is of course but I don't
think it's like hey while you're trying
to do damage the entire army of hive is
coming at you at the same oh that's nice
too much okay I don't think that's
generally the idea this is like low
arenas we'd all like to do that for and
then the big boys in there and you can
only damage him until you get that stuff
done yep I know sorta mm I like likes
that's it so I mean you almost have like
one more technical encounter because
before it was ish I feel like there was
like four sections but the descent was
pretty long but if you went fast you can
get through it pretty quick see at the
opening section arabistan shadow thrown
the descent for Gath and then they
climbed a Dylan car oh right this one
you have the opening necropolis
you have the ogor section mm-hmm you
have maybe it is for over section the
Wizards and then the boss yeah it's
about the same mm-hmm so I know it's
early so I got to get to you down yet I
can't answer that okay all right so you
can't answer right now no but um what I
would say is actually question as far as
our loot we all know shot at throne you
know and had wish hinder you know I'm
saying they had the cool little Easter
eggs and stuff like that we noticed some
Easter eggs I believe you know have we
confirmed that there's a no exotic tie
to the pit of heresy so xenophanes did a
machine gun has a part involved in it
kind of similar to the way it was before
so there are parts and puzzles and
things like that to get into that good
we could do I haven't got it yet I need
to and honestly like to get the gun I
don't think you have to go that far into
the dungeon either so you could probably
almost solo that part patience of course
but like you don't have to try and solo
the crazy totem part to finish the guy I
think that's earlier than that to my
understanding okay okay okay
the field the consensus right now it's
early you have not beaten it yet it's
still a lot but what is the feeling
right now in terms of Peter heresy in
comparison to shattered throne what is
the feel that's not fair they're so
different
come on like okay I choose you gotta
choose between your kids which is your
favorite child early what's that going
to be my first solo shadow throne right
now cuz I've finished it but I haven't
finished the other one if I'm like in
the encounter so far from what I've seen
this one seems to offer a lot of turn I
think the best way to do this lake the
shattered throne was the first time we
saw it
so like the opening section with Erebus
and it built a map and like okay so then
when I see this one was like this is
kind of similar not the same but like
it's like go to a different section
clear this out there's a little more
mechanics to it this time which is cool
so they evolved it so like the evolution
wise
the like the catwalks and like running
away from the throws when you're slow
that's one thing I like the ogre section
because it's just like pucker the whole
time just like hold on the totem fight
is rough the boss fighting seems pretty
cool I mean overall I think it has
potential to beat it you and be better
just because for one some people don't
love the black and white yeah yeah so
like the aesthetic may do it for some
the big boy fire boss versus a wizard
and three big Knights that they've seen
before just like he's very much unique
mmm so I mean the boss may do it and
then on top of that just the fact that
like for me it's like when I when I know
now when I go in a shadow throne that I
can see where I'm going
that's cool nice no but it wasn't as
obvious it's like hey is that just like
a skybox Tower right when you walk in
and you like when I said that necropolis
and you look down you're like I gotta go
down there and you're like the scale of
this thing you're like walking over and
trying like peek down and like check-in
the other side I'm like I don't even
want to go down yet like it does feel
very ominous and yeah it's rough so yeah
and I also think when you get to that's
what am I thinking of what part the
totem part those enemies tend to get a
little beefier so being a higher light
level is definitely gonna help you out
there so that's the part that kills me
hybrid said recommend enemies are
recommended 90 Jesus what for the boss
fight
not surprising cuz yeah the ogre cuz it
was like ogre was 970 Dylan Cole not 970
but it was was it 570 trying to remember
what they were in the forsaken might
have been five seventy-five eighty
something like that and it was like it
was a step up cuz you're like oh I can
see the dungeon and then we we'd the
first time I went through it with my
friends we got to voir death and we were
getting destroyed because we were under
level so it's probably simmer with like
the scaling because I know what that
fight stuff gets harder because like I
can work some stuff before the Wizards
and the Knights and stuff and then when
you get to that totem section I was
getting it's harder for sure we will
revisit this because I guess
in fairness in fairness you haven't
beaten it yet but III think I know where
this is gonna go but I will in fairness
I wouldn't wait until you complete it
and then we would do our full match up
shout it throne versus the pit of heresy
but I like what I'm hearing man I mean
this thing sounds really cool you seem
to explain very unique mechanics you
know between each I like the stealth
part I like the unique stuff with the
sword defeating different guys with
different mechanics with the sword
sounds cool the boss looks absolutely
amazing you made a great point as far as
just having that unique nature that look
you know I'm saying that like I know we
were spoiled for you but he looks still
cool man you can't take nothing away
from it and um yeah you know it's just a
matter I think for me it'll be my
determining factor once I get in there
will be I have to admit I gotta get shot
at throwing this you know the fact that
they had wish hinder the fact that you
know there was those secrets with the
eggs and the stuff like that I think
that I'm only we're only thing I'm
worried about Peter heresy is the loop
because we got to talk about it now go
for it yes talk about a sesh I don't -
is it a jab muskan show xenophanes
so um you know but I hear people don't
like this thing that's why I haven't
rushed together yeah yeah ding ding ding
ding ding so you know I heard about we
aren't about the gun obviously you know
say another type of guy I'll be honest
you know I got a lot of stuff to chase
so you know I'm waiting sometimes I'll
wait sometimes I'll kick back and let
you guys go ahead and let the content
creators go ahead and while I you know
finish our brother stuff just so guys
can give me a feel of once they got it
how are you feeling about saying god so
I want to shout out my man em test I
wanna shut up asked across they are some
hilarious refusin it's good and I sat
down like are you kidding me so no crit
damage is solar solar machine gun right
I believe I forgot the RPMs on it one
two pony
I think somebody 120 right so ultra slow
is probably the only tone almost
thing like a sniper slash machine gun
right so you're getting these slow delay
kind of shots and you know range is on
it there's no real kind of explosive
damage from my understanding and there's
no quick damage from my understanding so
yeah no shoutouts Asha shut up - show me
round up those Oh apparently she kind of
combines all our stuff from reddit
xenophanes not doing precision damage is
not a bug the weapon higher-performing
this is the bullet section is not
intentional and currently being invested
which is what I was gonna get - I was up
to date thank you for that sir um yeah
so at first you know everybody's like
y'all is this thing bug like cuz they're
doing tests on Greg we all know Greg is
you know say and it's like this is not
it like what why am I gonna be utilized
and then the ammo in PvP is atrocious
you have to get a three tap and you
barely have any ammo it is a joke and
BBB like so this gun I'm like where
where is its place where are we using
this over anything so happily thanks to
you information that you just provided
Bungie has jumped in form in front of
this there is no crit damage fine but
they are saying it's not working as
intended so I'm very curious to see what
what's supposed to be doing good in it
so that's all I was worried about in
reference to best saying that wishing
that was just oh my god I actually feel
um lemon Arkansas better people don't
use wishing therefore much except oh
yeah but you know say yo for taser for
that ain't no machine gun it's an
oversized hand cannon it does critic wit
they do it doesn't could okay yeah man
it's it's not a go so again I guess my
thing with it I just want to see what it
eventually will do and then I will judge
that I just hope there's some really
cool weapons and stuff
whip it that's all you know I'm saying I
that would be nice I mean I put it for
this cool I mean
edek you got a sniper coming you got a
rocket coming slug shot he's there those
are the three I know of
and then premonition pulse rifles like a
dream Bain type weapon so those are the
four ones that I'm aware of
yo shout out to high but he said I just
use wish nd to shoot eggs and si and
that's right and that's one of the
things for wish endure it's like it may
be like hey it's a cool quest to get it
but then when you get it this is one of
those things when Bungie designs weapons
that sometimes I question I guess yeah
you go through all of these PvE
activities you go in with a dungeon I go
in this like crazy mission killing all
these like enemies and stuff I forget
like the mini bosses then you go back
into shadow throne you summon the mini
bosses you kill those you finally go
through the dungeon and the best benefit
for this thing is seeing through walls
in PvP why is this PDE focused quest
guide shattered throne dungeon not like
yeah
piercing multiple enemies are like
shooting two arrows at the same time or
helping me like that what that is - it's
things when I get to it that's what I
was just about to bring up and I've been
listening we don't want to just sit
there listen these dungeons are amazing
right let's give credit where credit's
do these dungeons on fire these are a
unique things that they just debuted
with destiny to that we think is
absolutely fantastic but at this point
all we're saying right I think we're on
the same page there's that with the
effort that you put with this and then
we look at something like zero hour and
you look at something like whisper of
the worm read I'm saying like those are
weapons worthy of the quest yeah in my
opinion this Zeno whatever this is no
wish and no no they're cool
aesthetically but they need to be
powerful they need to have that look we
just went through hell to get these
things and it's it saddens me that most
of everybody in the chat including me
yourself is that these things are in a
vault chilling somewhere like we we are
not utilizing these things in any
regular capacity and that's the only
thing that saddens me because you want
that trophy you want people when they do
a dungeon but you know what weapon is
dead
what did you oh my god like you want
that feeling like now it's gonna make me
do the done yeah
now it's gonna make me because I want
that super powerful thing and they just
got to get that back raise their okay
for the most part but I feel like that
means raid Luda still has some question
to it yeah you're like I'm trying to be
nice with a curious I try to be nice
what was a curious was unique it could
blast some things but no no but like you
got a garden of salvation raid though I
mean like there are some cool perks like
there are some cool feeling weapons
people that came as pulse rifles all
diffusions like absolutely beasts there
are some really cool weapons in there
but they're not you got a recent I can't
even with a very bad you got no they're
useful he would separate would with that
raid decent not out a useful just said
Fred the are you 12 months of been
around for a year putting up with your
antics there sir but he's saying they
are useful they break down into five
legendary shards just like the best of
them that's coming at night that's
coated it coming into David listen man
that's all we meet yeah fear to be a
wish it this is an abortion isn't a
bushes for yeah man it just you know you
just want that level and I feel you know
where they knocked it out the park was
armed last wish like thousand K right
thousand K even though few like two
people in the world guy but doesn't care
yeah you can never get it you know
anarchy at least was unique you know I
try I'm saying but they do they gotta
step it up
the dungeons should have that level leg
yes make the quest sounds involved
hybrid saying like the final bosses like
980 level he's hard to kill he's gonna
take some work like all that stuff is
that is a journey to go through and then
when you get this thing and it's
shooting peanuts out of like 20 per
minutes like it doesn't feel disgust
disgust what is this
no I could help I am NOT doing
that quest I literally made it out to
see I am not doing it I don't know if
it's broken I don't care what it is I
was like that is I'm not putting myself
through that torture I'm not doing it
I'm doing the dungeon but I don't care
listen they're right there when I see
results like that so yeah yeah no but I
mean that's a thing I think right now
the bungee has actually a bigger problem
of and that is rewards that is rewards
for your encounters unique loot unique
perks things that make that encounter
worthwhile are there like unique raid
perks that make like hey when you're
tethered or if you're you know defending
a point or when you're dealing with
angels or Angelics or all of those like
even just little stuff like that like
hey when you're shooting in Jelks this
is more powerful hey then I might use
this weapon in here because it's a cool
weapon yeah same thing in the dungeon is
like if I go through this crazy journey
and you tell me this thing's beneficial
in PvP because I can see through walls
nobody gives a damn about seeing through
walls in PvE doesn't mean a damn bit of
anything for me cuz I'm like I need to
shoot whatever I'm shooting in PvP I'm
not gonna like see if anybody's come in
like that one is so backwards to me and
I'm the same with everybody else I shot
the eggs that I put it away it's like
that theater that served such little
purpose to go through shadow throne
itself is an awesome journey the
encounters are fun to solo it it's tense
and cool and when you do it you're like
hell yeah that's a fist pump like Dark
Souls accomplished type mo yes yes good
point good comparison and then this
thing is gonna be the same thing and you
can't get some drops from but you're
also potentially getting some of the
same drops from all tears of sorrow so
again is that the journey for the
triumph score and the emblem as opposed
to more of a unique reward from it
probably which is which is kind of
unfortunate because why does this
dungeon like the artists who made this
thing all of the work put into this the
scale the size the journey and then when
you get done you're like yeah you do you
get one pinnacle a week for noticing it
can we admit leviathans breath should
have been the reward right you survive
them breath hit like a truck you know
they shot the Bendis eye he brought out
his wish
the fur to get leviathans breath Danny
we're right back in the I go Fred I did
December I brought a little monarch out
but at least a little knock I felt got
utility though you know I'm saying like
it's like foreign Bowl you know saying I
felt utility but yeah man we got a all
you know it all I'm hoping is that they
you know we get a couple of patch notes
down the road and it's like you know 1k
is gonna do this anarchy is gonna do a
little bit more this you know wishing
their buff to this with some type of new
mechanic they really need to revisit
these things you want people in these
activities you want people to be running
this thing for these quote-unquote
elusive weapons that are unique and
super powerful and I think they're
slightly missing the boat here outside
of everything else being fantastic they
are missing the motive yeah it's like
the gameplay experience is really cool
it's just the roars right now need a
little love tweaking Bunji pocket again
yeah altars will keep you busy dungeon
is cool solo is gonna be rough I know
people have done it already but you guys
are crazy skilled that one guy out there
who's trying to go for power level 999
he was at nine ninety like Zuppa he is
that is he's I think he's season ranked
777 he's in the seventh six or seven
hundreds on his season feels like that
dude has been living in bounties nothing
but nonstop now so that is crazy I'm
still curious to see if level nine nine
nine does anything in shattered throne
maybe it does I have this tiny little
bit of like fingers crossed that
somebody gets to see that won't be me
obviously I think I'll be mine but oh no
this has been in insane week yes lot of
stuff man a lot of content a lot of
things to play if you don't want to do
the hardcore stuff
you got your momentum control you got
your festival for light-hearted fun you
know I'm saying you do man so this is
cool I will say this is a great week for
destiny as far as the format you know
and I know we got to talk about a
pinnacle sources in a minute but uh yeah
there otherwise I think this is just
still a great week for shadow keep as
far as content and hopefully like they
they continue this caters this is
really cool cadence and cool story
building and you know I'm saying got to
cinematic I look at a Cora she's still
building stuff back there well I don't
wait until portlet yeah we wait for that
to go left but um weird Cora Cevallos
gonna go over there and be like yeah
- left is the table so a lot of
activities going on this stuff is like
three three weeks going straight
basically like we got three weeks on
festival lost you've got three weeks on
momentum control so jump in do the stuff
you need to do in there so that'll be
good but then coming on November 7th so
like later next week it's like Thursday
patch randomly so yes weird they put out
the should we put out the public service
announcement now in reference to that oh
yeah we're getting there it's go go for
it so they have been hearing the
feedback about pinnacle we talked about
on the floor bassy basically being
impossible to reach 960 now someone will
set some will say like hey the Internet
[ __ ] too much and now you guys get all
the things you want now it's gonna be
too easy the other side are like I've
been nine fifty point nine for three
weeks straight so there's a debate back
there back and forth and I can see both
sides because you make it too easy then
you take away the phone we've been
through that and dusty - year one on the
other side some protection is beneficial
yes so on Thursday
remember iron banner launches Tuesday if
you finish your bounties save them do
not turn them please because on Thursday
when this patch hits pinnacle drops will
now be plus two instead of plus one mhm
and this basically equates to the fact
that you're only going to need four
pieces of gear to raise that average
number to 951 so then you can start
getting higher and higher
so you may not have as many sources but
now with that plus to your average
should start getting a little bit higher
right mm-hmm
and to help mitigate the whole you know
the curse of what I call the energy
weapon clinical gear like I'm the king
of energy weapon oh you and powerful
people I'm saying yeah oh so yeah I mean
what do you think this was what do you
what you feel and you think this was
good enough you think this is not enough
you do you want more you know we we had
a big you know I would say debate
because we both on the same page with
this but you know do you think the way
they're handling pinnacle gear is the
right route is this the right way to go
I was like said Fred said it pretty well
I think the debate should be on whether
or not there's a point to grinding after
you hit 950 max due to the artifact
leveling there's not much of a point in
grinding for me to pull your level up I
hit Fred ol fire right back I've
literally about to go away yeah I mean
you've got you've got the artifact so
the artifact does get slower over time
1.3 1.4 that guy at 990 like his next
level is like 4 million experience so
it's gonna be slower by the time you
guys grind up there so there's a point
where that's not gonna benefit you and
having all alternative to work on levels
and say hey if I do finish the dungeon
hey if I get my 100k nightfall that gets
a little easier if I get my nightmare
hunt because they're gonna slowly start
to trickle you up I think that was not
bad in theory mm-hmm the big issue I saw
with some of the higher level people is
like hey everybody grown so much now
people are gonna get to 960 so much
easier and then stop grinding because
they don't have anything else to go for
right so the 960 being like hey is that
the only thing to go for but again the
artifacts just really what's gonna keep
boosting you past 960 anyway right so
like for me I guess it would be nice if
it was like it could honestly just be
like a checklist cuz like some
protection in there to be like hey I got
everything but a heavy weapon hey go do
this thing get your heavy weapon okay
you're at 951 and the cycle goes through
the plus 2i well if it would be nice if
it's just like plus 1 or plus 2 and then
if you get to the point where you are
missing that one piece that's holding
you back yeah toss them that one and
then you got seven more to go
yet like smart orangy yeah smart orangey
with a little like 1 to 2 range if it's
always +2 now some people worried it's
gonna go too fast which I could kind of
see these are something you take away
the quote pinnacle but again it's also
gotta be attainable so that's the
balance of like baby it needs to be like
one to two so it's not always gonna be
the big boost maybe it's a little bit a
little burn protection in there I still
want the one you still want the one you
don't want the one to go away what like
+1 the +1 I mean I can see +1 me just
give him a range maybe every soft and is
a plus doing sweet like have those
little moments of surprise have a little
protection somewhere between where we
are now and where it's going I think is
where more people would be happy it's
like infinitely stuck at 950 sucks
straight up oh just a hundred percent
agree we've all been there and
especially if you're trying to go to 960
you're like why am I trying to do these
hard things if I just keep getting
energy weapons that is no fun for
anybody so that does need some type of
light hey if you get your second one
you're like oh but your third cool like
no more than to wait and start filling
in those other slots sometimes maybe you
get it plus two as well so that may help
balance out the protection a little bit
but if it's plus two all the time you do
four and go up four and go up four like
that average is gonna climb a lot faster
than I think they intend right so then
they heard a whole buncha Yellin okay
let's make it a little bit faster yeah
you don't have that many sources but now
you have the dungeon
you have the nightmare hunts you have
the nightfall iron banner is gonna be
four it's not gonna be seven it's so
that'll be less mm-hmm I don't know
somewhere in between I think is probably
where it needs the land I'll be curious
to see if people think this is too fast
for most people it won't be too fast I
will say that you me still probably not
too fast cuz we don't play we don't know
life it right the glads the dados the
chicks or Clyde's like all those guys
and gals when they're out there playing
non-stop that's the ones where it's like
they get every pinnacle every time they
may go too quick just again out of the
Marco Styles loot the Marco styles are
coming over from the leaving division
for destiny full time yeah
I had to shoot my shattered division
cool yeah well I was surprised he got a
great video but now I mean I'll jump in
you know I mean this is a weird position
for me this is very strange
um I am in this weird thing where it's
like I'm loving shadow keep I want to
continue to play hardcore but there's a
part of me that it's stopping that it
says okay let me wait into this pinnacle
thing get straightened out you know now
it's gotten it seems to be you know they
added a +2 I still think my gut is still
feeling that there's still not enough
pinnacle sources even though I know we
got the dungeon now you know I feel like
we just need like maybe one more
activity where would you put it okay I'm
actually curious because I mean I'm
wondering the same thing
we're noting so this is my problem
trials of course yeah of course you know
saying
um I think oh you know we're gonna do
that division slanted mailman to you man
came over your number-one guy Marco
style is now quitting we're gonna do
that slander I could talk my talk you at
the number one game now baby add those
dead divisions all that's over I got to
talk now that was supposed to be
Destiny's supposed to be dead again it's
my time to shop but enough talking
enough enough gloating anyway back on
track the whole thing is this like um I
feel like the problem with the pinnacle
gear and I feel right now
is that it eliminates me doing all the
other challenges right now I don't even
jump in game because I'm like what's the
point I'm not gonna get pinnacle right I
don't even jump in crucible no more
what's the point
I long it pretty so now I've eliminated
all these activities that I kind of
enjoy doing because I knew I would get a
reward to me the bounty stuff which may
be the new grind maybe I'm just not is
I'm just not adjusting as like yo this
is what I need to be doing just playing
it and doing the bounties and getting it
that way but it's like I wish not
everything was neutered from pinnacle
I get that we have to have the most
difficult activities but the problem is
there's not enough difficult activities
and enough sources to warrant you know
doing it and I still think they gotta
find a balance man that's that's just
where I'm at you know um yo feed a bit
he own fire and he said put pinnacle one
reward for Amanda Holly she is lonely in
a salute to Amanda holiday for having
absolutely no use absolute oh hey she's
still my chaperone it like 9:54 me yeah
she wish she's okay I gotta get him
cranly stay get making icord useful cuz
I got a problem with our core in the
past so I like what she's very integral
but yeah man begins that side of the
tower with what's-his-name but rockzilla
if sir is not over there I don't even
see that side of the time there's
nothing over there I didn't go over T
like that that's that's something but
yeah they got to they still need to I I
don't think it's balanced enough because
you have all this great content I mean
it's there okay so let's see this like
gamma 3 3 no it's like gambits like
three matches mm-hmm
okay that's you're powerful that's
powerful yeah
what if your pinnacle was like 20
you know what would that would something
Lonnie I'm like a where it's like chat
like more like is it like Vanguard
strikes rut by change Vanguard strikes
you see that yeah what was the tweak on
that I forget I read it and I was like
this is not the same it wasn't like it's
matched 300 his bounties it was Vanity's
yeah yeah it was like that was weird but
it's like maybe run 20 strikes like the
annoying people may hate that too but I
was like I don't use it let me tell you
the flip now you just nailed it you
nailed it you know how I felt about
knife Falls in d2 prior to shadow keeper
didn't do him in Doom I wasn't messing
around tinker oh no card I wasn't doing
no setting I ain't doing it I was just
like I'm not doing it and I had too many
I had other powerful sources I can do it
I felt that I can I enjoy that I can get
it my way right okay now they're like yo
run it five times
alright or whatever then they're like yo
but if you get 100,000 boom in
cent if harder challenging thing in the
same activity incentive when I see that
I'm not okay I'm doing these knife Falls
I did that night for this week it was
fantastic it was like the hog did the
i-beam it was very difficult I did my
first I think I was at nine fifty or
whatever it is for me that was my first
one but not making one it's my first one
I'll get came close to hundred thousand
we didn't get it but I had fun now they
need to do the same with at least two
other act especially there should be no
reason why I am NOT playing crucible at
all for a pinnacle no reason like I just
eliminated you know saying gambit these
are great moves it at least dose to me
those modes are like core molds so those
three so at least have it or my other
suggestion I don't know how you gonna
feel about this though my other
suggestion is why not put it in old
rates why not
Saro why not school get people in these
raids you know I'm saying
sois not you're not just locked into the
Garden of salvation loophole right cuz
other raids have heavy sources so it
didn't makes it and then you give him
value to the raids you're making people
jump in there that's what I want to see
cuz right now it saddens me a little bit
you see me playing out of worlds and
other games doing stuff because I'm like
yo there's only a couple of Pinnacle
sources I'm really not even gonna do
right now until Thursday again cuz a + -
what - it's gonna be the choirs it's
quite as Tuesday ever oh yeah yeah it's
cries we say so I that's where I think
they need to still tweet man they shout
- Jojo - great yeah rotate over
different old raid every week like they
got to get us some more incentive man
right you love us to do raise this is
the bet the best content in the game and
again if you guys haven't watched
Morocco Styles video please man
he's a division guy watch it but he made
a great point as to why he switches
he said the race he said there's no
other game that does anything like that
and I think they need to value those men
cuz they I mean looks gorgeous great you
got sorrow I want reason to jump in
levar then you given us armor 2.0 it's a
hole it would be a hole incentive just
to get in there
have fun so that's why I'm an no I mean
like I think that would be amazing at
weekly what is the weekly pinnacle rate
mm-hmm that's like that makes Dawn's yo
give this man your bungee you see my man
out here with these ideas you see them
high do you got it like yeah weekly
pinnacle rate or I'd say hey we're going
to crown a sorrow this week hey it's
Scourge next week last wish okay go get
those taking our movements like all
those names our options those are cool
got a shout-out to said I said I count
on real quick he said then people
complain they can't do raising funds is
locking about high content with without
time they can't do I get that too I mean
that's really a casual comment I'll be
for not you being casual but what I'm
saying a casual guy would say that but
the reality is they have all this unused
content they just say no I just know
great stuff and now it just relevant
relegated to just powerful gear that no
one's really gonna do once you hit the
950 cap so you gotta come up with
something you know I mean I'd like to
see like somebody said it earlier if it
was like even if it's like 20 wins like
what if its wins in crucible you can't
just like you can't just show up and get
a participation Melo you got a try if
you want that cynical you could do that
gambit you can do that in crucible I
don't know strikes does have the 100k
but your Vanguard list might get a
little empty so those would be nice
things to see like maybe this week it is
gambit more people play game bit a
little more popular maybe next week the
pinnacles like hey the weekly pinnacle
is now gonna be in crucible this week
yeah bro a weekly Vanguard strikes like
kind of give people like rotated like
burn through and then same like a weekly
rotate iterate like those would be give
you incentive give you another couple
drops not gonna be Ziggy like 20 wins
that could be for some Yuling hell it
could be like 40 matches for me if I'm
fight if you go on 50% that's gonna be a
lot of crucible but absolutely I'm
working on bounties always picking them
up now the other thing that I want to
add to all of this if we're I'm gonna do
like 20 crucible matches or 20 game of
matches or more yes please let me
somewhere in the director just pick up
the repeatable yeah let me and let me go
to the vendor if I need the basics but
someone I can go to the store
I can go pick up my milk and eggs let me
pick up my repeatable bounties from the
director then I've like go back and I'm
like okay cool I did it okay cool let me
switch while I'm going through and just
stay active in that playlist that's all
I want those were fetal bounties are
really nice I just hate going in and out
of the tower like every three matches
like if you finish them
I completely agree just I think you
nailed it and I think if they handle it
I would be out even go you know an extra
amount of sense of a rotating raid
pinnacle playlist you know something
that rotates it's just one of them and
then a rotating arm activity similar to
when for Satan came out and you know you
would check you know your your
challenges and then it'd be an extra one
today on crucible of me an extra one
today
yeah simpler than that yeah there's what
your junk in a map okay I can chase this
today I can do this it creates
engagement they got great content
there's no reason to to lock it off the
idea was cool they just the execution is
just a little off so they just and get
that together
but I'm would you Sheriff II you on it
man hiya Sheriff he's making XD great
again that's the only problem is I have
to go to my Bungie interview dressed as
woody and then I have to live in this
costume so I'm gonna get like six of
them I got a whole call up Halloween
stores personal dry cleaners to make
sure this thing always stays fresh this
is ridiculous guys I can't live and
share it forever it's I can't do it yo
what you wear look how these great ideas
you know can I just leave the hat on
this is gone just a hat I can roll with
that I'll figure out my headphones we
don't cut holes in it or something but
there we go to infinity and beyond
here's the absolute what is it a
building yeah so that is the big thing
to make note of it's like pinnacles plus
two starts Thursday so if you do your
iron banner drops make sure you don't
turn them in until that goes live
they're also gonna throw a few of the
season pass weapons they pull perfect
and that new machine gun into vex
offensive so little more in there which
is nice because that's gonna be coming
likes likes iron banner comes the heavy
ammo spawn is gonna change in there as
well so that'll be going so even more
incentive to do crucible so get your
scout rifle kills continued going in
there
mm-hmm that's the community podcast has
their charity stream tomorrow they're
doing DCP wot F game nation special
guest Pete Parsons all gonna be so heavy
bro you got people our salute to DCP
they got Pete parson CEO of Bungie and
Beth's friend of Xbox uh Phil Spencer
Anatole my xbox and then the Bungie
bounty is the newly miksa fide King Jeff
a lien on PC also on Saturday 10 a.m. to
noon so literally you're gonna have the
Bungie bounty from 10:00 to noon and
then and that's that's literally
tomorrow ok I work and get and do that
crap mm-hmm and then noon pacific so 2
p.m. my time mm-hmm the DCP thing goes
life so Bungie bounty and then DCB
charity stream still going remember I've
also got a link if you guys want to
donate you guys have been on I think
we're almost at like I think seriously
almost at 2000 1910 right now you guys
have been awesome so far so if you guys
do want to donate it's the iPads for
Kids program that's what all this stuff
is all about by the way mmm
kids Bungie Foundation great great stuff
other than that check if there's like is
it not use burden kind of got fixed and
then broken again and I'm broken again
yeah so there's issues there if you do
have like Forge keys or obsidian crystal
or rare bounties mm-hmm
hold on to them if you got them don't
turn him in just hold on for now other
than that I think that's the main one
cuz that stuff hasn't been fixed yet
mm-hmm but yeah I think yeah I think we
got a lot of stuff so like I mean when
you log in and when I was like even
thinking I made a video the day before I
went live but I was like this could be
one of the biggest launches until next
season with everything that we've got
it's you got the new public event which
is basically the new escalation protocol
in altars of sorrow the new dungeon
xenophanes just an option out there
which good better otherwise it's the
thing and then festivals going for three
weeks with your new Auto rifle and union
activity to do and candy to collect
everywhere make sure you're wearing it
like so I didn't say it earlier if you
go to altars of sorrow put your mask on
yes like you're gonna be killing so many
enemies consoling there candy is just
falling everywhere and then every
nightmare you kill is like a strange
coin it's not or every wave you finished
so it's like if you're out there trying
for a while just make sure you do don't
mask on y'all
put the mask on and crucible every kill
is for candy every match is like strange
coins have that mask on in everything
you're doing right now it's that 9:50
it's not that bad bad question but I
know we wrap it up soon but I had a
question for you um wait like you said
it like this has been a tremendous week
we would agree write a lot of content
you know we really can't complain we see
banner stuffs coming back my question
now with a dungeon we've got a dungeon
we've got a gardener salvation raid my
question besides your dogs barking is is
do you think do you think next season of
the dawn are we allowed to complain if
there is no raid no Dutch I can probably
read about you neither of those will be
in there I can pretty much agree to I
won't be surprised dungeon we've had one
a year hmm if you go in there you see
the scale this thing this is not an easy
thing to make it's not something they
just lop out even the wish endure not
wish enter sorry um whisper the worm and
zero-emissions are not the scale of this
right so while those can still be
developed they are still not the scale
of this dungeon and the mechanics this
the enemy's V it like even just them all
of the pieces of this dwarf those that's
why when I say dungeon
there are now two in the game there are
not four right whispers those are heroic
like missions mm-hmm so you're wondering
like so what do we get we get a new vex
offensive the portal goes through we
have the final assault whatever wraps it
up ceases infidels like hey enjoy your
new vex offensive and all your old stuff
is that what you're wondering how I'm
just curious I'm right now I'm more
seasoned adorned
time I think shadow keepers going
fantastic I'm loving without like shadow
keep ivory outside of Pinnacle so I said
ideal vessel salute there's a row
outside of Pinnacle sources issue the
cadence and the content has been in my
opinion phenomenal it's been really good
and especially remember this is just
them too so I really can't go money so I
guess I am very curious because even I
mister demand a lot from the studio you
know I'm that guy right so even I'm like
yo I can't complain if there's no raid
in season that it dawn I can't complain
if there's no dungeon in season of the
dawn
so my question I've just the back of my
mom like how today we know it's gonna be
a smaller thing right we we would assume
it's not gonna be on the size of shadow
keep it'll probably go back in
you don't line with opulence and and
black armory size or whatever and we
know narrative is I'm confident that
they're gonna handle that well you know
I'm saying with your transitioning into
it you know like I know they're gonna
have a Cyrus he's totally there I'm
gonna keep quiet that's the hope if they
have oh sorry okay what do you do it
already Maddox it automatic season pass
of the year but automatic a plus plus
check is bad I'm biased is how is how is
clumping they just they literally just
save the word Osiris and you're like
bought it thrown money at bought a gun
taking every ornament ever verse and
said I'll just sold out I bought it all
bought it all everything Egyptian wears
go so anyway but thing is how can they
get us engaged I'm just curious because
I'm pretty calm I'm like you eat I'm
pretty confident those two things are
not gonna be there what could they do if
they are not there well to keep us some
type of activity three person or six
person you could imagine hmm I mean that
had like the infinite forest if you're
bringing Osiris do you think it will be
PvP related I don't think that's coming
yet I think if they're doing PvP that'll
be like them
because I still think they need time
with what they learn from crucible labs
and the feedback I bring yeah I think
that will be later I honestly don't know
I believe that they have ideas of stuff
for us to do I know it's not easy with
everything they've thrown at us I'm like
how can they try and make anything else
I feel like this is what most companies
put out in the year and they keep
putting stuff on top of it yeah so yeah
thanks offensive is gonna go away yeah
we're not gonna have our moon invasions
sad face but what if whoa I mean take
another planet have that be invaded like
you need to find a way to make some
public spaces be Lively because that was
cool I like what they did with the VEX
you know some type of like whether it's
a race getting pissed off whether it's
so I mean obviously we've had fallen and
vex on this one so you got cabal and of
cabal and fallen would be or two maybe
one of those is mad about something
they're gonna go you know drilling back
in IO or something like I don't know but
I can see some match-made activity right
we should assume right quest or two of
course season absolutely interesting see
what that thing holds I think we get a
honestly like a zero hour II kind of
think West trying to think behind me
will be long it will be on cadence
whisper was like September and then
whisper or then op you that was during
your hours just a drifter so if we got
dungeon now yeah I guess cuz like
whisper was before shattered throne in
those tech let me kind of code came out
fairly close actually
right I don't know I don't see a full
dungeon maybe a cool exotic quest could
be like March maybe but yeah I'm overall
just like yeah I have no clue I really
don't I can picture some match-made
activity because that's typically what
they've done whether it be forges
whether it be reckoning whether it be
opulence right those have had one thing
like that to keep us busy but mmm beyond
that dude I don't know what about you
I'm I'm feeling kind of like I don't
I'm feel clueless right now I'd really
don't know yeah I think obviously you
know we got that activity that you I've
been wanting you know that would be a
nice trials would be nice you know it
would it would it would really really
great the base we have weekend stuff to
do that's the thing a lot of people
don't realize what trials also did it
really incentivized weekends you know
I'm saying and um basically was like two
sir trials combo of the you know of d1
so that right there if it's not ready
I'm still okay I'm not gonna go crazy
but he got like two seasons to get it
together
gotta be by March yeah you got two
seasons and then I'm gonna start ranting
again but I'll be nice you already know
which I don't want crucible labs um I
think they they should be on point for
or 0 hours last whisper the horn faction
rally my man Neil mental I'm Sam I guess
I that like something like that would be
a good filler because if trials isn't
ready I worry about them trying to do a
game but focused anything because that
was not well-received and they'd already
said one of their damage is going yeah
so the evolution of that might be like
year for with it to whatever works
yeah I could see like faction rally type
something like that maybe not
specifically faction rallies right but
something kind of like that where it was
like the two different sides of the
vanguard of the drifter or I could see
that type of theme going on something
where they're building towards that I'm
very curious about seizing it done but
uh had to bring a bit like you'd be
proud of me I've lowered my expectation
I'm not being unrealistic
cuz I'm I'm thinking about the dazzle
those hard-working devs and if you
giving me good content so when they give
me good content you get a little bit of
rope now you get a little did good imma
be like exactly but if it's bad content
that whip will be crackin two seasons
don't get trials of Osiris
that's about all I got too so watch your
pinnacles next week wait till Thursday
to do that stuff Thursday's apparently
gonna be the big day but other than
that's that's been a lot yeah as like
dungeons dungeons are really really cool
solo and that thing is gonna be a
journey definitely have to see what
strats are working out there the light
level will probably help a little bit as
you go but all in all that thing's been
really fun altar is a great addition to
the moon and the fact that that's gonna
stay around a school definitely fun
grind hopefully piggy will figure out
what to do mm-hmm
okay apparently weren't Q&A right now
we'll do the skewer - I kind of want us
to do that like if you guys have
questions I want to get gay less you do
that mm-hmm like kind of the end Q&A if
we got time the content creation
question what type of content would you
make would make you start out with when
you made Destin love the video creation
process about a get get stuck on wanting
to do weapon review content updates just
tips and tricks videos what would you
success biggest thing about content
creation ask anybody who does it make
what you're passionate about that's the
easiest thing I can tell you is because
that's where you're gonna have the most
fun like hey I'm gonna put a whole lot
of time to this guy because I really
enjoy it or man this weapon review is
really in-depth but it's like I really
enjoyed it
do your thing again I can't tell you
what to do because honestly what I enjoy
doing versus what asked across this cool
guy versus fallout
I can't copy those guys cuz I'm not them
yep that's a great that's a great point
if I do a weapon I was gonna say if I do
a weapon review which I've really never
done but if I do one it's not gonna be
the same as anybody else's it's mm-hm to
find what you do you think like do you
think it's a good weapon do you think
hey these are the perks that are
available here's the roles you want to
go for maybe a god role thing or I mean
all those to figure out what you want to
do my solo guides have just been
something because like I was passionate
about it I wanted to do it now let's see
if I can help other people do it that's
just been like what I've done the news
the tips are like things to do as well
but what were you gonna say cuz that's
mine is my
do what you want to do no I think for me
it's it's it's it's look I think Forte
first of all he is super passionate
about that man
that man's carried me through stuff so
the passions there he loves the game um
emailed it do what you are passionate
about first for me I don't have half
this feel it under you guys as far as
concentration and video editing but I
know what I like to do I like to run my
mouth about destiny I'm good at that I'm
when it comes to running my mouth about
destiny and about the direction of the
game and and how passionate I am in this
community you know I feel I'm up there
with anyone else so my thing is like he
said do what you're passionate about if
you wanted to be you know a weapon
review or whatever definitely if you
want it to be tips and you do what I
think you've got to channel you got the
platform you know we support your
brother so long yeah man I think that's
great fantastic advice man yeah I think
you should do it you're you're super
knowledgeable guy and you love destiny
so that's the that's that's the
foundation I say for anyone's get
started
shadows if you're it fear the beard go
figure would be my first weapon review
hey 40,000 kills at least I can talk
about it but honestly yeah that's kind
of the big thing is like whether we're
talking about this on here whether I'm
making a video whether somebody's stream
in a game that they enjoy do something
that you enjoy doing if you have fun
that will carry through into everything
else your passion will be behind your
content your ideas will be just like
genuine you're not trying to like copy
and steal or like hey I'm gonna do news
or to keep up with this like do what you
if you want to talk about the news talk
about the news how you want to talk
about the news now there are ways to be
more efficient about it to like manage
the YouTube algorithms and try and be
better but to start just make what you
want to figure out kind of where your
lane might be and then go from there
like figure out what you want to do
that's the that's penalizing I agree my
advice and that's probably where we can
wrap it up so you guys have been awesome
today we are gonna go raid us somebody
so hang out in chat please don't leave I
want to give somebody a love for you
guys to go surprise and say hello to
but for now tell what you got going this
weekend yeah already no Sunday the iron
law podcast returns 11:00 a.m. Eastern
Standard Time be in the realm on ILP
YouTube channel we will have a guest it
will be undead 3 xvi please check us out
man we're gonna have some special
announcements please check us is gonna
be really really fun you know again
thanks very much support and you know
I'm saying far as the Iowa podcast
movement I've seen a lot of growth
lately a lot of love I see a couple of
you guys come in here too it's really
cool to see and um you know we're just
growing man trying to grow this thing
obviously on the channel you already
have King David with king of the statues
he's got a cool funny hilarious hala
he's in the spirit of like a he's in the
spirit
he's all just diagnosed for what it is
but it's funny all you saw it's
absolutely hilarious he went all the way
with it salutes my brother King David
you already know and yeah man please
check out Lords of gaming dotnet you
know I'm saying for all the latest news
and information and gaming and one last
thing I was gonna say also check me out
on Sunday I'm going to be reviewing this
bad boy which is I've been console
streaming X cloud or a console streaming
and been playing a lot of destiny on the
go
cellular and Wi-Fi so I got a mess that
bill I got a baby
Verizon now here we have Fry's an LTE
you know saying so um remove it but lo
let me tell you right now man just early
impressions
if Xbox can nail this thing where other
people's configurations everybody's
configurations can work this thing is a
tremendous potential so um yeah check it
out I've been your boy been up getting
his destiny on on the go man it's been
it's been fun it's been really fun so
yeah that's all I got and you already
know every Friday morning when I'm not
that late or is not that late 9:00 a.m.
Eastern we come back to the campfire to
talk to y'all you know talk about this
nesting thing the last word debate argue
joke
have fun with you guys you guys are
tremendous I really look forward to you
guys give me energy when we're in a chat
and I really appreciate you I really
appreciate doing
the last word with E even when he's
sneezing when I'm trying to give him
credit
hey I'm you to the mic damn it yeah I
know you guys have been awesome
seriously thank you guys hopefully
you're enjoying as much as we are right
now cuz we're having a blast in this
game lots of stuff to do it has its ups
and downs like anything and then there's
this other other stuff that dropped
yesterday the embargo for big old s
trending dropped this morning so so
that'll be something that'll be a
different journey later on so thank you
guys very much next week's show is quite
questionable I don't even think that
one's gonna happen yeah that's right
next week though interesting yeah we'll
figure it out there may be a video the
pops up later but as for live show can't
promise anything just anything so stay
tuned on Twitter if something pops up
probably just gonna be on video my guess
but other than that stay tuned so it'll
maybe a week break and then we'll get
back for 81 probably on two weeks from
now so it'll be like the 15th but other
than that for episode number 80 stay
tuned we're gonna go raid Zoey go say
hello to her she's awesome definitely
keep you guys awake with her accent so
thank you guys for episode 80 of the
last word I'm sorry I said that totally
wrong I butchered it made all mean what
do you see he's not use of this the
sheriff - sheriff a usin a sheriff hey
who's this so alright guys well thank
you very much go say hey to Zoey for
November 1st episode number 80 it has
been the last word